hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
facial transcriptomics revealed insights
into the melanoma tumor
micro-environment
i am michelle ashton of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by alumina and 10x genomics to learn
more about our sponsors please visit
www.meliar.com/mpanel.htm it's calm
let's get started before we get I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send transfer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the asks question
box located on the far left of your
screen this presentation is educational
and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Aida
solar dr. Stephen hey Kim rain and dr.
Hannah Erickson for a complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
our speakers will now begin their
presentations
hello today I would like to talk to you
about exploring biological systems at
single-server solution with Illumina
sequencing technology
let's start by jumping right into the
science this is an article from the
single cell space that has been
attracting quite a bit of attention it
is a joint effort between the broad and
the Massachusetts General Hospital and
what this researchers did was to
profiled around 7,500 cells from the
windpipe the nice thing is that they did
it both using the 10x approach and a fax
based sorting full-length RNA one as
well afterwards all the sequencing was
carried out using the next week 500
system when they analyzed the data they
saw that the windpipes lining consists
of seven different cell types and not of
six different cell types as was
previously released the interesting
finding here is that this new cell type
the IANA site depicted here in purple
expresses a high level of the cystic
fibrosis transmembrane conductance
regulator or CSTR which is basically the
protein responsible for cystic fibrosis
this means that the current
understanding of the cellular basis of
cystic fibrosis is likely to be complete
since instead of being a common cell
type expressing CSTR being involved in
cystic fibrosis it might be
predominantly this new unknown until now
cell types that is involved in this
disease
this is something that wouldn't be
evident from Volk study because then all
the cell types which is have I reached
out each other and you wouldn't be able
to find these rare but very critical
seven types of lung cell well this is
just an example from the literature but
of course there are many more
taking a look at the trend in single
cell publication numbers you can see
here that it's almost an exponential
growth curve
the graph here starts in 2009 it's
because in that year the first
single-cell sequencing article featuring
NGS is published and as you can see
there has been a 40 times increase in
the number of publications since then
taking a closer look at the 2018
single-cell sequencing publications in
high-impact journal we will see that
there were 20 nature 15 published in
science and 25 himself adding up to a
total of 60 articles and that meaning
that there was more than one published
per week so as you can see single cell
is increasingly being applied and it's
impacting multiple areas like cancer
research human ology stem cells and
development as some examples
so why single cells well because each
cell is unique and having the ability to
look into individual cells can tell you
more about the underlying biology
in this example that we see here we have
two collections of cell a and B if you
treat them both in a bulk fashion and
you look at the blue transcript you will
arrive at the conclusion that the total
transcript number in population a is 6
under the total transcript number in
case be6 as well so this may lead you to
the conclusion that these two situations
are exactly the same but these are in
fact two very different biologies in
case a all cells express the blue
transcript to a certain extent whereas
in case B most of the cells are silent
being only a few cells that Express a to
a very high level
so having single-cell resolution you can
actually chase casing and case B apart
and that can show you more about the
underlying biology like would be the
example that we just saw in the Cystic
Fibrosis paper where instead of the
Cystic Fibrosis receptor being in a
common cell type he may be more confined
to a rare cell type that expresses it at
a higher level and this may lead to a
very different conclusion
what we're also seeing is that there are
many different new methods coming out in
the single-cell world initially single
single cells started mainly in the RNA
world and right now you can profile
three prime five prime RNA full length
RNA and you can also look at doing
targeted RNA but currently there are
also many other biological molecules
that you can look as well
like for example proteins targeted DNA
and you can also look at different
regulatory features like for example
chromatin accessibility there's also
very important trend towards multi-omics
to see as much as possible or to get as
much information as possible from this
single cells one example of this being
the fact that site seek approach is
becoming quite popular since it allows
you to look at both RNA expression and
protein expression in the same cell so
if you can see single cell is no longer
a niche application but it's being more
and more broadly and more routinely used
there are also many technological
advances being made and developed and
with these technological advances cells
can be isolated faster easier and more
in Streamlight mode as well as being
able to study all these different types
of biological molecules that we just
mentioned and not only on
there are so many improvements and
developments happening in the analysis
side of things
these include graphical tools graphical
interfaces to help you analyze single
cell data in an easier way but there are
also groups working on getting more
information out of existing data one
example being shown here and it's RNA
velocity it is basically an ingenious
bioinformatics tool that tells you where
the cell is actually heading based on
its RNA data from an RNA slick
experiment you can get not only where
the cell is based on its RNA expression
but also where it's heading in this
example you can see for example the gray
cell in the gray group that's in the
brighter upper corner you can see it's
vector its RNA velocity pointing toward
the direction of the yellow group of
cells so it's most likely that this cell
is going to become this yellow cell type
with this what you can do is follow
cellular trajectories and see how
development is proceeding the beauty of
this application is that you do not need
to rerun your experiments actually you
simply need to reanalyze the data that
you already have
so all these basically shows that single
cell is not a one-size-fits-all
application you can have different study
aims or you can look at different
molecules or you can do it on different
scales but one constant is that we are
Illumina support all single cell
applications with a wide range of
systems no matter what you want to do we
have a sequencing system that matches
your output me from the icig which could
be used for library to see all the way
up to the Nova see which will enable you
to do large-scale single cell studies
featuring hundreds of thousands of cells
so if you have any questions about your
particular research or project on how to
do sequencing in the best possible way
please do not hesitate to get in touch
with us
we also want our system to be as
flexible as possible so that you can use
the same system for multiple
applications you might seem for example
that you want to deeply characterize a
particular cell type here depicted in
the blue cell group and that you want to
see if there's only a single cell type
or if you can be further subdivided you
have around the thousand cells and you
sequence them to quite a high pass of
500,000 reads per cell
so the sequencing output for this study
is 500 meeting total deep and this is an
excellent fit for the SD flow so on the
other hand if what you would like to do
is more an ADD listing' approach you
take around 200,000 cells of a
particular tissue or of a particular
organ to understand what is the cellular
composition of the tissue or organ and
you profile those cells at 50,000 bits
per cell needing 10 billion reach in
total and this is an excellent fit for
an s4 closer so as you can see you can
do both this study and also everything
in between using the same system simply
by selecting the optimal flow cell to
use so again we would be more than happy
to help you out with any questions or
any doubts that you may have about your
particular project
our technologies have been used in a
large number of single cell publication
and here there are simply for example
from the different buckets that we
mentioned before you will see an RNA
example in the blue area chromatin
accessibility sample until proteins in
purple and the name breath and if you
are interested in reading more
here is a great publication review which
is about over 100 page PDF showing how
single cell sequencing has been applied
across multiple fields and it also
features different methods that can be
used like RNA epigenomic and DNA at the
single cell level
and with this I would like to thank you
and I will pass you over to Steven hey
from 10x
you
thank you either for the introduction so
just to run through and some information
about 10x genomics to start with so when
when we look at the sort of biological
system so we have an example here
they've looking at the human so it's an
incredibly complicated system to try and
understand and we believe that when we
work down to single-cell resolution that
we really gain insight kind of how this
organism functions so we obviously know
this that we have approximately 40
trillion cells in an individual we have
approximately 6 billion DNA bases in a
diploid genome and sort of 50,000 mRNA
molecules can be transcribed so it's a
really complicated system and really the
mission statement of 10x genomics is to
try and make tools that enable the
researchers to delve down into that
great resolution and really understand
what's going on down at the single cell
level so if we just have a very quick
overview of what what connect is all
about so we can see the top that panel
the slide that we provided a number of
instruments which we can use the
partition cells into droplets which you
see in the middle portion and were able
to be effectively barcode these cells so
ultimately when we're looking at gene
expression we're able to do this on a
single cell level and then were able to
build that data back up since fairly
complex and feed me parts to really
understand the biology I guess where 10x
sits as well is that we we provide a
number of novel assays and biochemistry
and we've invested a lot of R&D effort
and analysis software and visualization
tools as well so we really try and
support the researchers across the whole
area of single-cell genomics um recently
as you may know we also moved into
spatial transcriptome it's with an
acquisition at Swedish company sort of
the end of 2018 so that's really going
to be my focus my short introduction
today so 10x has been around since or
really so first commercial product back
in 2015 which is really based around
link read technologies what ran about
2016 and onwards we've really focused
our efforts into the single
so genomic space and we've released a
number of tips of developing
complexities of move from straight
single cell gene expression that we're
looking at such as immunology as well
and being able to look at cell service
proteins and look at things like CRISPR
profiling as well and then as I
mentioned what we've done very recently
as we move slightly left the field and
we've moved into this notion of doing
spatial gene expression so being able to
take Christ at sections and really look
at profiling what's happening on a
molecular or gene expression and profile
into the individual tissues so you know
why is that of interest to researcher so
to move away from the straight
single-cell genomics field a lot more
into profiling tissues and this slide
just gives a very kind of quick
introduction to the notion of why we
might want to do that so basically in
the two panels a and B what we're
looking at is two two tumors and you
know visually when we just examine these
they appear to be very similar on the
morphological level but if we're able to
profile these on a molecular level and
we're able to look at gene expression
what we can actually see in a versus B
so the tumor has got poor prognosis
whereas atrium has got better prognosis
if we look at gene expression profiles
of lymphocytes and we see actually when
we look at this that there's a very big
difference between these two tissue
sections so what we've seen in panel a
is that the lymphocytes are actually
able to penetrate into that tumor and
initiate an immune response and really
combat the progression of the tumor rows
and be those lymphocytes are held around
the periphery of the tumor so they're
not able to kind of effectively fight
the tumor so that this is kind of giving
us sort of batarangs funding really into
the biology of what's happening here
which we may miss by conventional
methods so that's just really the notion
of why people are increasingly
interested in the use of spatial
transcriptomics
so the solution that we we have
currently and also developing an R and D
is just shown a so it's a simple glass
slide and on there we can
array
catchup raised on it so the slide shown
at the top consists of six subarray so
that means in this iteration we can
section Christ that section on tissue
and then we can mount that on to the sub
array so potentially between one and six
separate christ-like sections on that
and if we look down at the bottom left
when we look at the civil rate and what
we're seeing here is in the current
iteration we have one thousand and seven
spots so we can mount our price back
section on to the sub array and we can
go through a process of fixing and
permeable eyes a permeable eyes in that
tissue and when we do that they are
enabled to diffuse out and then we can
capture that RNA effectively so if you
look over on the right-hand side of the
slide we see the capture probe and if
actually what's going to happen is the
RNA passes down through the cell that
will be captured onto the poly T and
capture region and then what we can do
from there is we can amplify that and we
can make a library so what's important
when we do this is we incorporate we're
going to do the first run T donation
systems you cook incorporate a spatial
barcode into the cDNA and that
ultimately has the D convolute the data
back to each one of those sub arrays on
the slide and the kind of work that we
are seeing all over we will be
supporting is so for example here we can
we can see a section for mouse brain and
this is looking at hippocampus which is
outlined in this red region in the sort
of center of the slide and we can sort
of orientate our gene so obviously what
we're not doing here is we're not doing
targeted approach to doing this so this
is hypothesis free in a way that we can
capture all the expressed genes
potentially and it's shown here what we
can do is we can highlight that region
of the brain and then we can just simply
look to see which genes are expressed in
there and we can rank those in terms of
the expression profile and now I'm
moving from there we can do things are
so in here so we can highlight again
head comes and separate areas the mouse
brain and what we can do that is we can
compare and contrast the gene expression
within the brain there so you can see
down at the bottom right that we can see
volcano bark so we can see genes
significantly regulated shown on the
right hand side of the slide
I'm genes are significantly
downregulated to shone red
I'm the ones that remain saying showing
blue in the central portion now so we're
able to do this kind of compare and
contrast between different regions in
this case of the brain and we were able
to really gain insight into the biology
of the tissue that we're looking at as
well so that's the current iteration of
the spatial transcript omics and what
we're currently working on is to move
away from this a little bit and we're
introducing the vision and process so
this works in a similar way and we'll be
streamlining the workflow so that the
time two results will be improved or
shortened and we'll also see improved
sensitivity around there and we'll see
an improved resolution round about this
so this is where we are going with this
product and we will aim to release this
in q4 of 2019 and then just as my final
slide so this is a recent venture that
what we're doing is we're actually
inviting people to submit excited to
construct so 300 words in total and we
will run our vision project for you so
that's in terms of the sequencing and in
terms of the slides and the detail more
details can be found this connects
genomics comm challenge spatial so we
invite people that are interested in
this and have novel projects please feel
free to submit an abstract absorbs and
we will judge that and we will choose
the winners a number would be the
process for you so thank you very much
for your time I'm not talking Lee
hi everyone and welcome to this webinar
my name is Kim Shawna and I'm here today
with dr. Helmick Erickson to talk to you
about spatial transcriptomics and
titanius malignant melanoma
I'm with a spatial traffic Atomics
research group which is some epidemic
group led by Professor Li walking down
the bay he found the dissipation
transcriptomics technology together with
assistant professor posix Doyle and
professor Jonas JCM and it was published
the first time in science in 2016 in the
lower left hand corner you can see a
picture of science philosophy auditory
or phyla flab this is a research
institute in stockholm where the
technology was developed and where the
spatial transcriptomics research group
is based below the picture you will find
a link to Silas labs web page as well as
our group's webpage where you can find
out more
I joined the group a little over five
years ago and since then I've been
involved in various projects one of them
is a collaboration with dr. hammock from
where we use facial transcriptomics to
explore heterogeneity in taneous
malignant melanoma and we published a
pilot study in cancer research last year
I'm going to share some more results
from this study but first I will talk
about the concepts of space
transcriptomics and how the technology
has been further developed by 10x
dynamics to become this Y M
the basic idea of speed
Atomics was the bridge histology and RNA
sequencing by providing a histology
image as well as large-scale gene
expression data from a tissue section
simplified the workflow is to stain and
image the tissue construct the
sequencing library from mRNA captured
from that same tissue sections and then
visualize the gene expression with
spatial context
this visualization can for example be
the total gene expression or total
number of genes detected or you might
want to see the spatial distribution of
one or a few selected game
this figure shows the location of
clusters from melanoma data panel will
tell you more about these results later
on and I will also show more examples of
data visualization
towards the end of this presentation
in the lower left-hand corner we see a
list of some publications from the
spatial transcriptomics research group
and as you can see we have applied the
method to a variety of organs and
diseases such as miles of factories
breast cancer heart ALS and even plant
species you can find more publications
on our webpage through the link to the
right
you
the very heart of spatial
transcriptomics is the esti slide it
looks like a regular microscopy slide
but has six identical capture areas
what I'm showing you here is what we
call the 1k slide meaning that each
capture area has 1,000 spots and this
was the first slide version and one that
we used in our melanoma study I will
come back to slide versions in the next
slide but let's first take a closer look
to spot a spot is a cluster of millions
of immobilized oligo DT primers these
have a spatial barcode that is unique
for each spot and additionally they all
have cleavage sites a t7 promoter pcr
handle and a unique molecular identifier
or umi the structure of the primers is a
little different in the 10x genomics
vision but the concept with a spatial
barcode is the same
the spots have a diameter of 100
micrometers and the center-to-center
distance of 200 micro meters furthest to
the right we can see that one spot is
covered by a variety for get the same
barcode in the sequencing data again the
slide I'm showing here has 1000 spots
per capture area we have since then
upgraded our slides to 2000 spots for
more recent projects and the 10x vision
slides have increased to 5000 spots per
capture area on the tutee slide the spot
diameter is the same but they are closer
to each other and on the 10x vision
slide they are both smaller and denser
providing higher spatial resolution I
will come back to the 10x vision slide a
bit later so stay tuned
here is a schematic figure of the tissue
preparation workflow that is all the
steps that are carried out on the glass
slide first of all a PV section is
placed on a capture area and this is
followed by fixation can epoxy on a
nails and staining and imaging after
imaging the tissue is permanent life and
somatically and this will allow mRNA to
be captured onto the barcode at oligo DT
primers
reverse transcription will extend the
bar-coded primers with cDNA and the mRNA
cDNA hybrids are then enzymatically
cleaved off from the glass slide
we keep the glass slide inserted into
cassettes with a rubber mask to get
individual reaction chambers for each
capture area then after the cDNA has
been cleaved off from the glass slide it
will carry a spacer bar code and can
therefore be pulled so that we will get
one sample per capture area
I will not go into detail on the spatial
transcriptomics library preparation
which is quite different from the 10x
vision version but I thought I'd
mentioned that for the last few years we
have been using an automated approach
developed by dr. and the Shemp and
published in scientific reapportion 2016
for the finished library we use Illumina
present sequencing to get the spatial
barcode and um I read one and be in
information 3/2
I mentioned that spatially
transcriptomics have been used on a lot
of different tissue types but still the
protocol may need to be tweaked a little
bit and especially in the feminization
step or the pamper mobilization time
the goal is to open up the cells to
maximize mrna capture but still keep the
structures intact so that the mRNA will
not diffuse horizontally and hybridize
from two spots further away
to optimizations we have a separate type
of life that we call the QC file however
in the ten xscape they are called teo
flags
instead of having spots the capture
areas are uniformly coated with oligo DT
primer and these do not have any spatial
barcode
so here the mRNA can be captured all
over the surface and then fluorescently
labelled nucleotides are added to the RT
reaction
will vary by guess your essence cDNA
wherever mRNA was hybridized and the
tissues undigested and the slide water
before imaging
the resulting fluorescence image it's a
cDNA footprint of the tissue and we can
see that it reflects the morphology very
well with a strong signal is held them
serious
however it's not only about cell density
some tissue structures or cells tend to
be more transcriptionally active
other than thermalization time there are
some additional parameters to take into
account for example we have sometimes
had problems with tissue cracking which
is typically a result of the freezing
procedure sectioning thickness as well
as staining protocol may be change
depending on tissue type or preference
in a particular study
the RNA quality is also important and we
typically extract RNA and check the rim
value on a buying life so before we get
started with a spatial and comics
protocol
I mentioned some of the issues Hammond I
encountered when starting with melanoma
lymph node metastasis
the very first thing we noticed was that
biopsies look very different in size and
cell type composition as you might be
able to see from the images because of
this we ended up optimizing the
permeability time for each biopsy
although is normally only have to
optimize one for each tissue type
also found some biopsies to contain a
lot of pigments or melanin melanin is
known to inhibit reverse transcription
but what we found to be the initial
problem was to get these sections off
from the graph which in turn made their
optimization tricky because of all the
fluorescence and images
in the end we found a way to get the
tissue off thanks to generous and
elusive OVA was working with us for her
multi pieces then we could proceed with
optimization and the results do look
promising but we didn't include these
biopsies in our first study
we were concerned about was the age of
the sample the oldest one had been in
the freezer for 20 years when we got
started but that's one actually scored a
ring value over seven and gave a decent
FG library so I guess the take home
message here is that over the samples
need to be fresh frozen they do not
necessarily need to be fresh
tamo will continue on the topic of
melanoma shortly but first I will switch
focus to 10x vision which I got the
opportunity to try out in July this year
as a part of their beta program what you
see here is a vision slide and some
specifications
as I already mentioned the capture area
have 5000 spots and there are four
capture areas per slide
the spot diameter has been reduced to 55
micrometers and the centre to centre
distance to 100 micrometers this means
for higher spatial resolution with only
1 to 10 cells per spot depending on
tissue type
it's capture area is marked with a
border that is visible in the tissue
image as you will see in the next slide
and this is used to align the sequencing
data onto the tissue image
for the beta program doctor and the limo
link and I'm prepared vision gene
expression libraries a mouse brain we
then sent the sequencing data to 10x for
analysis with a pre-launch of the
pipeline here are some preliminary
results but I will go through very brief
to give some examples on what you can do
with the data
to the left we have a Chandi staying
tissue with a board around as a deaf
mention and to the right we see the
total number of unique molecules for um
ice take the purse pulp and since the
scale bar is not very clear I can point
out that all the spots that are bright
yellow got around 40,000 um ice each
now to the right we have the total
number of games detected per spot
instead of your mice and here bright
orange is equivalent to 6,000 genes
as I said in the beginning we can also
focus on one particular game to see how
its expression is spatially distributed
in these two images we have eg r1 and
HPC a
and here we see ie FB p6 and TBR one
lastly we can cluster the data and then
get spokes colored based on cross
refinement
and with that I would like
everyone in the spaceship
transcriptomics research group you want
horizon's' group at Karolinska Institute
funders and of course 10x do not make
hi I'm Hannah Eriksson and I'm working
as an oncologist at Karolinska
University Hospital in Stockholm Sweden
I share my time between clinical work in
the field of melanoma and also clinical
and translational research and today I'm
going to present and follow up on the
presentation by Kim Drona espeacially
resoled transcriptomics and which
enabled the section of genetic
heterogeneity in stage 3 cutaneous
malignant melanoma
she canis melanoma is one of the most
aggressive of all skin cancers and the
incidence is increasing in those
countries with fat skin populations
early detection and surgical removal of
the tumor is still crucial for the
prognosis and survival in the disease
early stage melanoma has a relative
5-year survival of almost hundred
percent whereas metastatic disease used
to have a very short survival of six to
nine months before the introduction of
novel therapies such as targeted
therapies and checkpoint inhibitors the
prognosis in stage three disease which
is lymph node method sized melanoma is
very heterogeneous and the survival
varies between 40 to 70%
and I know most one of the most
genetically but also in you know
logically heterogeneous of all cancers
activations over several signaling
pathways and of the immune response are
involved in tumor progression and
therapy resistance but the biology of
melanoma also gives several
opportunities for potential levels
therapy targets thus further research is
needed to elucidate the molecular
mechanisms underlying melanoma biology
to improve the diagnostics and to
identify prognostic as well as treatment
predictive biomarkers
the inter intra molecular hydrogen
virginity in stage three melanoma have
already been analyzed with an array or
analytical approaches exiting gene
expression analysis immunohistochemistry
and proteomic approaches single-cell RNA
sequencing is a powerful tool for
addressing transcriptional heterogeneity
but knowledge about the spatial origins
of single cell is vital when studying
the humour micro environment we
therefore aim to optimize and apply the
spatial transcriptomics technology for
the in-situ and quantitative detection
of gene expression in stage three
melanoma lymph node metastasis and for
this purpose we analyzed the
transcriptomes
over almost 2200 tissue domains in fresh
frozen tumor sections by retaining the
position information of the Tia domains
we could superimpose and the
transcriptomic data onto histological
tissue images and visualize gene
expressions throughout the tumor
so the aim for the project was to
optimize the size of station Transpo
mechs technology for the insight and
quantitative detection of gene
expression stage three melanoma lymph
node metastasis
and now I will show the results for
melanoma we did a pilot study to assess
whether spatial transcriptomics would be
useful to study heterogeneity in stage
three melanoma first we optimized the
protocol for lymph node metastasis and
then prepared the esti libraries on
these four biopsies in decades as well
has had them examined by pathologist who
annotated areas of melanoma lymph weed
and stromal tissue the samples had been
previously genotyped for some common
mutations and we also had information of
the outcome of each patient and they had
been classified as long and short terms
survivors
here is a short data summary on average
fifteen thousand genes were detected per
sample and around three thousand unique
transcripts per spot
a correlation was typically lower and
these samples compared to Mouse
olfactory bulb likely due to
heterogeneous nature of cancerous tissue
before exploring the spatial data we
merge the counts for each sample to
mimic bulk data at PCA then revealed the
strong separation across patients and we
analyzed if s T could detect sub areas
with shared expression profile
the next results I will show you are
based on a data-driven analysis - that
was developed by dr. Jonas Mascola
in the Lindbergh Reuters silence lab
basically the data from all spots in all
samples were decomposed into 20 factors
or clusters and each cluster was
represented by a spatial activity map
and the gene expression profile this
illustration is simplified to only four
factors the third panel shows the
spatial activity maps that is the
location of a cluster a factor and below
are the top five genes for these factors
but actually a set of 50 genes was
generated
so now we have these 20 clusters and I
would show a few of them but here is a
first visualization of all factors with
t-sne in color space here the spots with
similar gene expression will get similar
colors above are they H and E stained
tissue images with annotation and now I
would relight two of the samples
sample 1 & 2 were the only ones that had
a lymphoid tissue annotated by the
pathologist and these areas are marked
we yellow in the HD images in the top in
the t-sne they both appeared blues so it
seems that these areas shared expression
profiles the tumor side tower appeared
to be patient specific also it is
interesting how sample 1 from a
long-term survivor had a homogenous
expression pattern in a tumor area in
contrast to the very colorful sample to
from a short term survivor this could
represent Yuma heterogeneity being
related to outcome but of course we
can't draw any conclusion in this
exploratory study
when comparing the spatial activity maps
to the histological images we found four
factors to be particularly interesting
these two here both have spatial
activity maps that correspond to
melanoma areas so we label them melanoma
A and B they overlap to some extent but
not always example one for example
seems to have a melanoma a but not B
whereas sample 2 has a bit of both the
expression profiles of melanoma a and B
included both cancer and Yuna sociated
genes for example C D 63 in melanoma a
is reported to act as a tumor suppressor
whereas F 100 B is sometimes used to
follow disease progression
we found factor corresponding to
lymphoid tissue with high expression of
for example CD 74 which has been
associated with the recurrence free
survival and overall survival in stage
three melanoma the Lowell panel shows a
pattern that was not an updated by the
pathologist but with Estie says it was
clearly in between the tumor area and
the lymph fluid area we call the
transition area several of the genes in
this factor have been associated with
resistance to checkpoint inhibitors and
they seen genes have also been linked
with tumor growth regulation through the
Gadd for the five J&K pathway in other
cancers such as in viable stomas along
with other immunogenicity acquired
resistance to pd one blockade in
patients with melanoma through defects
in the pathways involved in the firm
receptor signaling such as bien I'm
sorry I had to take it again yes or no
that's what I'm sorry problem at all
yeah good
so I go for this picture again we found
one factor corresponding to lymphoid
tissue with high expression of for
example c2 74 which has been associated
with the recurrence free and the world
survival in stage three melanoma the
lower panel shows a pattern that was not
an updated by the pathologist but with
st since it was clearly in between the
tumor area and the lymphoid ayah we call
the transition area several of the genes
in this factor have been associated
resistance to checkpoint inhibitors and
the genes have been linked with juma
growth regulation through the Gadd for
the five J&K pathway in other cancers
such as in glioblastoma along with loss
of immunogenicity and acquired
resistance to PD one blockade in
patients with melanoma through defects
in pathways involved in the interferon
receptor signaling affected such as b2 m
and the antigen presentation
we were interested if we could find out
more about the transition area and in
order to obtain a more detailed view we
analyzed the samples individually here
with PCA when clustering the data from
sample one indeed we found the spots
from the transition area form the
cluster of their own
we then looked into what genes that were
differentially expressed and had the
highest patient of orion's and visualize
them as heat maps these are some
examples
peameal and SPP 1 are both melanoma
markers and these are clearly enriched
in the tumor site
I mentioned that CD 74 is associated
with better outcome and here we can see
that these this gene is highly expressed
in the lymphoid tissue first away from
the tumor whereas IG ll5 which is also
immune related is mainly expressed in
close proximity to the tumor in the
transition area
to summarize we optimized this patient
transcriptome as protocol for melanoma
and with the data-driven analysis we've
found a shared expression in healthy
tissue multiple cancer profiles within
the tumor and identify transition areas
in tumor microenvironment
the results demonstrate the in training
to zoom of gene expression heterogeneity
we generated a more detailed portrait of
the heterogeneity among melanoma
metastasis and we showed the transition
area which may be a component of the
fully understand the tumor progression
in future integration of the spatial
component into analysis of multiple
factors underlying human relation and
therapy outcome would be of the interest
and I will thank the patients the
professor you working learn the base
group professor Han do one houses group
the founders and ten aches thank you